do you have thoughts on biden's simple
rule tweet
mask or vax i have not seen the tweet i
had not heard of it but
you can intuit it from the question
um i'm not thrilled that we seem to be
losing nuance
i guess maybe that's just enough like
we've said enough about we've already
answered several questions here
about yeah actually um
saying that even in close spaces
um
[Music]
i i'm not sure i even want to say
anymore yeah i will just say
um in the context
of what we explored in the first part of
today's live stream how the hell can you
turn this
into a simple binary
where you have a choice mask or vex
first of all masks are not
fantastic protection the vaccine
is not a secure solution right we have
masks are better than nothing you're not
saying i'm not saying masks are nothing
i must say i think that there is some
nuance that needs to be explored with
respect to masks and
you know it's now we've now been doing
this with masks long enough that we're
in a position to know a lot more than we
did
but but the point is i don't want
i don't want team blue wagging its
[ __ ] finger at people who are
concerned about vaccine hazards i don't
want them
who is joe biden to tell us that you
know it's
mask or vax when joe biden was on the
team
that thought we needed to be wearing
them outdoors until two weeks ago
yeah right the fact is these people have
burned their credibility on this yeah i
mean the cdc's recent pronouncement
about
if you're fully vaccinated you don't
need to wear masks indoors or out
like how about how about let's start
with what we do actually know and have
done for 14 months now
regardless of your vaccination status if
you're outside and you're any distance
at all from people you don't need to
wear a mask full
stop that what that gets in the way of
though
is the assessment of whether or not you
have a star in your belly or don't
and so as long as we have these rules
and this you know this actually this
this little piece of video that you
showed me that i guess eric your brother
had tweeted yesterday um from
rachel maddow um basically revealing
that um she's been feeling virtuous for
hating on people who are not wearing
masks outside
yep and she's trying to wrap her mind
around what it would mean not to be able
to assume that somebody without a mask
was a bad person
it's you know
this is the administration of unity
apparently i see
unity i see no i mean i actually see a
lot of evidence that they're trying to
do exactly the opposite that the
divisiveness
um that that even trump spurs recognize
trump loved that he helped did he
facilitated
that he augmented but no he did not
fully create
that divisiveness that we all lived four
years through
looks a lot different in the biden
administration very very different
but the divisiveness and the the
political winds from keeping us
hating each other and looking at scans
at each other is very much alive
and you know for those people who were
so certain
that a win for team blue last november
was going to change
that environment well you were wrong
yeah like this this is just
just a a nightmare scenario in which we
are being divided at every possible turn
yeah and i i must say as long as we're
on the topic of that matter
thing i do feel like it is
you know one hesitates to use the term
proof but it's as close as you're going
to get
to the revelation of exactly what you
were hypothesizing about
sneetches right as far as i know you
were the first person to say anything
about that
and the sneachness of it was revealed as
matto is wrestling with the fact that
the rules of the snitch game have now
changed
the good people are now no longer
recognizable by the symbol
that had been agreed upon by the people
with the npr tote bags
and you know and the fact is okay so we
guessed right yes you were doing that
yes you all knew that you were doing it
and now you
you want to you have to you know get
around to
accepting that actually no the good
people are the ones without masks
because they've been vaccinated
i mean okay screw your game you know
yeah it's garbage
yeah it's entirely a social game and
it's antithetical to
a scientific attempt to understand the
world yeah
and it it's anything but we're all in
this together which is what you've been
pretending we're all in this
together and therefore you have an
obligation to do this and to do that
when in fact your advice has been
low quality to begin with and oftentimes
uh simply about finger wagging right
masks outside that was never
there was no evidence ever that that was
a good idea yeah